okay
okay guys this is my first live so
welcome everyone let me just make an
announcement in my discord i am live
hey hey what's up how are you
hey bro
okay hey morning how is utter looking
all right first question let's have a
look at cutter
so
what do we have
so let's take riot
okay so you want to see utter i was
following utter quite closely guys the
past few
weeks and we got some
yeah
all right so let me make a ta here
so i'm gonna start on the daily time
frame hi everyone good morning amc yes
so at their first so what i see guys i
start on the daily time frame i'm gonna
do my usual ca
so the first thing i see on utter is
that we have this
uh we had this downtrend you know for
almost uh one year then here we had this
massive breakout then retested it then
we went higher and then guys uh we tried
on discord to get into this trade we are
using stop losses so we entered around
uh eight
and we had a stop loss at seven all
right y7 because it was just below this
trend line so right now if i
need to say something about utter i
would say that guys it's not looking
very good to be honest
because we are below this trend line i'm
not seeing any
um reversal sign at the moment um
in this kind of situation it's always
interesting to see if the
rsi is
oversold or not it's not even oversold
if the rsi was oversold i would be uh
thinking maybe we're going to have a
bounce uh right now but i don't see it
oversold so i'm not very positive on
atar
i would become more positive
if i see
if i see the price action you know
coming back above this trend line so we
are talking here about 6
57 so if at all trades above seven i
would start to be more bullish
hey everyone so i see a lot of questions
i'm very happy to see all of this
so next one sdc alright guys so let's
have a look at sdc
so we were following this one as well
for quite some time
i don't think we tried to get in um
so sdc is not looking bad it's not
looking bad to me alright so once again
i'm on a daily timeframe what i'm trying
to to
to do when i do my technical analysis as
you guys know i just tried to find some
reversal signs and here
um i see this trend line the blue trend
line that is just here
that
is for now the resistance line we tested
it once twice in september and october
and we need to go through this and then
i would of course turn bullish all right
so we need to have something like this
and here i would be a buyer uh right now
i think
it's not too bad we are close to the
lows all right so the low was at 470 but
we have a support at five so it's a fair
try to try to get in right now and we
can check on the shorter time frame i'm
gonna go on a forward time frame guys
um
because on the daily time frame i can
see that i need some more bullish price
action to be bullish on the long term
but on the shorter term
we have some positive signals we have
here a little bit of a breakout above 5
30
and we
have here the recent highs let me get
rid of that then
okay the reason highs we're at 550 so
right now we're at 5 40 in pre-market so
if we close for a full hour above 5.50
there's something to try that's there's
something to try definitely
so i hope i answered the question well
hello everyone hi
hi
all right so yeah let's talk about gme
guys the the purpose of this um
this live stream is to focus on amc gme
uh i'm also i also want to talk about
fiscal if you guys are interested tesla
is doing great uh so let's check gme
first gme is just looking amazing okay
for the past uh
for the past week
so
so what do we have here guys
all right
there is a lot of drawing here i agree
um but what is important to focus on
here let me get rid of some of that
drawing
bam bam bam
this one is not important anymore
and we're gonna keep this one so uh jme
is looking very good since we broke out
above 185 guys all right this level uh
was for me a very important level
because it's coming from this trend line
and we broke it two days ago doing a
very strong move with always guys
whenever you have a breakout you need to
check for the volume all right if you
have a breakout without volume then it's
probably a fake out just like we had on
amc i'm going to come to this very soon
but let me first finish on gme
what i'm seeing here is very positive so
we have this breakout then whenever you
have a breakout that is you know a
sloping breakout
um
it's already a good signal to me it's
enough to get in sometimes if i have a
good consolidation just below but what
i'm looking for is a new high because
whenever you have a new high uh you know
higher highs higher lows this is the
definition of a bull trend and here the
height that i wanted to uh close above
was
192 and we closed the boat two days ago
and as you guys can see yesterday during
the day
uh this level was as most of the time
whenever we have those uh breakouts
those sloping breakouts the level is
usually retested because bears are still
you know just trying to put some
pressure and here it was retested at 192
and then we moved higher we made a new
high which is very good uh the
pre-market is looking uh strong at 214
right now this is what i see
so my take on gme guys is i mean we have
no more resistance um until 230.
so i believe that if we go to 230 we
might see you know some kind of
consolidation maybe a first rejection so
i'm gonna pay attention to this level
i think we're gonna have something like
this you know maybe here a small
rejection consolidation and here it's
gonna be very important of course what i
think personally is that we're gonna
have this breakout maybe then re-test it
and then we we would go higher but you
we need to also be aware of the
alternative scenario that we get
rejected we come back to have support on
this trend line just like we did
when we were um
in
on the 27th of october
um
so this is the alternative scenario and
here we gonna have again the same thing
until my my take is we have the break
out so
i'm very positive on gme i think we're
gonna go to 230 and then let's see if we
do breakout or not and if we do break
out you guys know what is my target i
can show you quickly here again
so
i think we're gonna have a fifth wave
that is going to 800 basically and the
reason why you guys know how i like to
find my targets i measure one plus three
applied to the bottom of the force wave
that is here and i use the 1.618 which
is the golden ratio and very often when
fifth waves are extended they go to this
level so let's see if we manage to break
out above 230 and if we do we probably
uh would run up uh higher and maybe to
800
so let's see
i hope i answered this correctly as well
you're the goat thanks bro awesome thank
you very much man just a sec i have some
okay
all right guys so what else jmemc let's
go yo andrew sense okay sense sense is
interesting uh
we had this one in uh our portfolio for
quite some time
um we had some options actually that
expired and we have decided to keep our
shares and i think we did good
so
let me tell you what i see on cells okay
uh i'm as usual i'm gonna start on the
daily time frame guys and we have here a
big big uh cup and handle it's actually
a double handle you can call it like
this you know so
basically we have this trend line as
usual guys uh and we tried we tried to
find um
the level above which
bears would probably uh stop the
position they probably would calculate
and bulls would increase the buying
orders and they would push the price
higher and here what i see guys today
i'm already in this trade so i won't uh
add on to my position right now but if i
was not in this trade i could go in i
could go in just because we closed above
this blue trend line
which level is roughly guys as you can
see at you know 380
so we are in the situation where we just
have we just had the breakout so it's an
early signal and to confirm that we are
actually moving higher i would like to
see a close above 4 15. so this is my
view i think we're gonna go at least
test this level then maybe get rejected
or maybe not and then let's see what
happens
but i think we go to 4 15 we ask a
question and let's see what the answer
would be
some positive for sense
all right what else do we have there are
many questions i'm very happy so i'm
gonna try to answer all of them guys
uh all right what time is it we still
have one hour before the market opens
okay fisela i want i want you to talk
about fiscal then i'm going to do amc of
course guys i haven't done amc yet
so
let's do first fisano
so fisela
is a trade that we are in as well we
bought some options here
um
okay the pre-market is not great so here
let me get rid of some of those lines so
that you can see better bam bam
okay i don't need this one
okay so if you sell for me the um the
signal the buying signal was given as
usual guys after breakout after sloping
breakout like we had here whenever you
have a sloping breakout that is broken
with volume this is an early signal that
can be used to enter a trade this is my
method this is what i'm doing
and it's working pretty well then we had
a run up to eight corrected here many
members were asking me here uh are we
still bullish and i answered yes uh
because we are above this trend line uh
as you guys can see for atter for
example we are unfortunately trading
below so this is the reason why for now
i'm not positive on utter but i was
positive on fisel then we had this huge
run up okay
so this was um
very good
but
the little issue i have right now with
fisel
is that we
we should be in um in a third wave we
should be in a very impulsive move um
so it's fine to have one red candle but
if we have one more it won't be looking
good we would lose momentum so here what
we need what we need to do is to pay
attention to this momentum so i don't
know if you guys see well but i'm
keeping an eye on the macd and you can
see the daily macd is going higher okay
great we still have momentum on
so high highs uh on the price action
high highs on the macd no divergence
we're good
then
you you know those divergences they can
be tricky
so we need to check on many time frames
then if i check on the forwards time
frame guys we are losing momentum all
right on the first time frame so this is
the reason why um i'm a bit careful on
fisell i would personally start to exit
my position around 9 50 10 today okay in
this area uh only 20 maybe of my
position and uh i'm still positive for
the coming weeks uh but i'm a bit afraid
that we pull back here and you know do
something i don't know so
what i would like to see to be really
positive on fiscal uh is a close above
98 980 why 980 guys as usual
you take the previous high and we have a
high here okay but it's not really
counting it's not a real high and the
first real high that i see is here at
980 so if we and you can see that this
is the level we got rejected uh the
level we got rejected was also um
the level that was on the upward sloping
trend line that you can have connecting
the highs in the recent move up and you
can see we had a double resistance at
this level
so yesterday we were almost trading
above so i was positive i didn't take
profits yesterday i gave it a chance
it didn't close above so right now i
would slowly start to reduce my position
uh if we pull back i would probably
increase again my position and if we
have a close above 980 um today or
tomorrow uh it would be looking good
again now
what levels should be should we be
watching today guys on fusel um
it's
kind of
obvious i would say here because it's
the recent high once twice on a daily
timeframe you can see one reaction on
the 18th of october at uh 8 90 second
reaction the day after and yesterday
this is the level where we found some
support
so
let me
show you another technique that could
have given us the support
uh once again is the recent high that we
had here and in yesterday's move if i
measure you know this wave and i apply
fibs it is the 38 38.2
retracement level so this is an
important level and this is the level
below which so i repeat 890 if we trade
below that level for one full hour today
um
this means that we would have lost the
short-term momentum and that we would
probably come back to the eight area
where we have some support uh once again
the eighth area is a nice support area
because you can see yes this was um the
one of the recent highs it's also the um
where we started to have this gap up
so to me if we close if we trade one
full hour below 890 i think we're gonna
go to eight and then probably go higher
just to conclude on fiscal i'm bullish
on the stock because as you guys know
this is um an energy stock and i'm still
positive on gas on oil we still have
some room left
some quite positive for all those energy
stocks
oh right i didn't do amc yet
hello from canada hey bro what's up
jason what's up man
okay
so jason you want to see sophie okay i
didn't do so few many times let's see if
i have something on this one
i have something oh okay interesting
okay i'm
all right
so so few technologies okay
so i'm not in the stock
but i'm gonna try to analyze the
situation here for you guys
so
it's looking great the first thing i see
is that uh you know i just do some basic
trend line and i have so one two
reactions so i i use that to build my
trend line and then you can see that
this trend line has acted as resistance
just here we got rejected we
consolidated just below which is
positive if the consolidation is close
to the breakout trend line uh
it's usually a good sign and usually we
have a breakout coming after that so
here this is what happened and we had a
breakout two days ago that got
retested yesterday
almost we had a dip around 21.
uh i'm quite positive on sophie guys you
know i might even add it in my portfolio
it's looking great
i would need to you know do some more dd
check the news so i'll do that later uh
of course we need to check the volume uh
very important like i said guys if you
have a breakout without volume
it's usually not a breakout all right
so here we have support as well on the
50 period moving average
so i'm positive if i needed to do
something here i would be a buyer i
could buy now i could buy slightly lower
121
and i would use a stop loss
but as you can see usually for stop
losses i like to use the previous loop
all right so here the previous low is at
19.15
so either you use that as a stop loss or
if you see a moving average that is you
know acting very well as support
uh it's good to use as well and here you
can see the 50 uh period moving average
on the first time frame is here acting
very well as support so right now this
level is at 20.7 so if you want to make
a more aggressive order not financial
advice at least for now
i don't have a professional license yet
but maybe i will do very soon let's see
um but i would personally uh i think use
that as a training stop loss and get in
this trade maybe i will tomorrow let's
see
but it's a interesting setup
okay what else do we have
targets for amc but bro you should know
the targets for amc but i can repeat i
didn't do amc yet so let's do it and i
haven't posted any video for quite uh i
think for two or three days guys
i was not feeling super good but right
now i'm feeling much better so
i'm here to
analyze everything you guys want me to
analyze so
amc big big um
stock very important
let me quickly remind you guys the
situation
because it's quite important to
understand what happened here i was
talking about breakouts and fake outs
and here we have a beautiful example of
a fake out so
first to have a fake out we you need to
have a trend line and as you guys can
see we had here a trendline that is
connecting one two three four we had
four reactions five six and then
suddenly we broke out on the 27th of
october true we broke out but guys
uh
it's a bearish signal but where is the
volume there is no volume so whenever
you have this kind of information
um
you know
it's just good to remember that a
breakout without volume
usually ends up being a fake out then we
came back what i wanted to see what i
was telling you guys uh on my discord
and in all of my videos is that i want
to see the price action coming back
quickly inside this triangle so
i hope you are seeing well basically we
have here a massive triangle guys a b c
d e all right so this is a corrective
pattern that is usually found in the
fourth position of eliot uh in the
elliott wave theory and uh in this
situation it's very funny to actually
see that one two three it's a force wave
so
what i really do believe and for
sometimes you guys know that is that
after the false wave will come the fifth
wave so the question we are all having
is
um
is it coming
and i don't know but it's looking great
it's looking great because we are coming
to the end of this triangle all right
the end is like early december
um so we might still see something like
this all right
it's very possible right now the
pre-market is at 40.6
41.
uh okay i don't have any resistance
before 44.
so
i
to to me i mean amc cannot really uh
correct before
uh going to the 44 resistance where
bears are waiting that's true guys
there's some bears waiting there and if
we go there we're probably gonna get
rejected first and then probably break
out sooner or later so this is what i'm
waiting for that's why i put here a
green
rectangle and then we need to uh so if
this happens
if we do
break out above 44
the last one we would need to break out
above is as usual guys we have a
breakout coming from a sloping trend
line
then we need to make a new high and the
last height that was used
in this trend line is 52 so 44 and 52
are very important i think we're heading
right away on 44 we might even see 44
today uh if we see today i'm afraid
we're gonna have first selling uh
reaction maybe not but usually we do
when we come you know from the from the
lows like we do here
um
and then let's see what happens but
i think it's the right time for breakout
because as you guys know we have results
coming on the 8th of november
i read that the tickets were selling
very well in the past few months so
maybe the results are going to be very
surprising on the upside maybe this is
going to be a catalyzer
for investors to rush in this trade
so we have many um reasons to think that
something might happen soon
um and once again i'll i'll keep
monitoring that for you guys and
and let's see but
sooner or later i think this fifth wave
would come and targets you guys know my
targets they have not changed for uh
maybe
five months something like this but
since basically may right
because whenever you have uh the top of
the third and the bottom of the force
you just measure it using fib
projections you apply the move to the
bottom of the force wave okay which is
here the bottom of the force and it's
giving me
in this situation 137
um so this is my kind of high target if
the fifth is extended and the one-to-one
relation can happen too so 95 so i think
that if we break out above 44 then 52
uh 72 will not hold all right this
all-time high would probably not hold
and we would at least go to 95 probably
137
and if we go there you guys know that no
one knows what could happen because you
know there is so many shorts uh there
are so many shots in this market
anything can happen
so this is my view on amc i'm very
bullish for the end of the week and i'm
waiting to see what happens around 44.
all right guys
so what else do we have what time is it
still
40 minutes left before market open
that's pretty cool
amc please okay that's done
w okay
hello ceo andrew hey gary yo man what's
up
hey paula you're here
nice to see you
can you talk about wish okay let's have
a look at which wish was in my watch
list
i think
oh sorry guys i need to reconnect to
bloomberg i lost my connection give me a
second
okay
so i'm wrapping bloomberg i'm using
bloomberg to get you know all the data
that i use in my spreadsheets
i can't really work without it
so you wanted me to have a look at wish
i know the stock
okay as you can see i have my drawings
guys because
okay it's interesting
all right
so let's start from scratch i mean not
from scratch but let's
up just a sec
all right
let's start um
let's analyze the situation so we are on
a downtrend right that's the truth we
are just you know
going uh
lower in quite a brutal way
uh for the past year the good news i see
the first thing i check you know is the
volume and we have a price action going
lower with decreasing volume all right
high lower highs lower highs
so it gives less
um weight i mean to the uh
to the bears here less power to the best
so
we are bearish and we are looking for
reversal right let me get rid of those
rectangles
uh
but actually those rectangles are here
guys because this is uh the way we're
gonna find reversals and here it's
looking pretty good what i'm seeing all
right the reason why i think it's
looking good i don't see increasing
volume so this is what i'm missing okay
um i'm still on the daily time frame now
i'm focusing uh on this area guys okay
here
i'm focusing here because uh this
is the first trend land we want to uh
trade above so right now the level is
560 roughly so if we trade above 560
we would have a first breakout then we
would need to make a new high above 6
30
and then i would turn bullish
and
the truth is that
um
we can anticipate those breakouts it's
not easy it's a risky game but you buy
lower and to do that what i like to do
is to check at the volume if i have an
increasing volume with the price action
going higher getting closer to the
breakout trend line
i like it it means to me that maybe some
insiders have some information
some people know something that's why
the volume is growing people get
interested in the stock before a news
and usually before breakouts
you see an increase
it doesn't need to be big but you need
you see a small increase in the volumes
getting closer to the trend line to the
breakout trend line and then we have the
breakout so i don't know what's going to
happen here um
but if we have a breakout once again
above 6 30 it would look good to me but
once again as this trend is quite
bearish i would need to see more than
that guys to be honest to be really
bullish i need to see
a price action
trading here right around seven
750
760 something like this so the question
you might have is
wouldn't it be a good idea to buy now
and to take profits at 7.50 yes i think
it would i think in wood and the reason
why i think this would be a nice
opportunity is because you can see that
here the move down uh is weaker
here we were going sharply lower and for
the past month we are basically
consolidating and this is usually giving
bullish divergences just like we do have
here okay so we don't have the breakout
yet but we already have some good signs
of reversal we have here a bullish
divergence right
so a bullish divergence you guys know
that whenever the price action is going
lower and the momentum indicator is
making higher lows this means that the
bears are out of steam and that probably
uh something uh might happen soon i
usually like to wait for breakout and to
combine it with the barrier with the
bullish divergence
but
um but it's a fair try to get in early
and hope for a breakout with a stop loss
you know below the lows so roughly below
450 you know you can even use this trend
line i don't know if you see it well
but you know this is the type of trades
i could do as well you know just try to
get in and stop loss you know just
around 480 something like this
and and just hope for uh for reversal
but we don't have the bullish signals
here to me yet
okay
hey
all right so what else bb
okay
i can talk about bb let me check quickly
the other questions see if you have
okay
wkhs i'm gonna do this one
wow live yeah bro we here
tesla yes of course i'm gonna talk about
tesla
okay so
let's start with
pltr clf
okay w w k h s mustafa bro this one is
for you so
let's do it
okay wkhs
all right
so as usual guys
i have my trend lines ready as you can
see
i've already checked this one work horse
all right so let's check what what those
guys do
okay
design and builds battery electric
vehicles all right it's easy okay
um everything that is related to eevee
right now is uh to me good
i'm not sure for how long uh this move
is gonna last i would say at least for
one more month uh it would actually be
driven to me by tesla i'm gonna show you
my analysis on tesla
but here we have some good reasons to
think
that
the breakout
could happen all right we don't have the
breakout yet let me check if this one
is in my watch list
give me a sec
okay i'm gonna have a look at that if
it's not i will add it you know what i
like to do is to monitor actually those
breakout levels
okay
okay so what i would do here i would add
this if it's not yet i would add uh this
in my watch list and whenever we have a
close above eight uh i would probably
try to set up a trade so for now it's
looking great i think we're going to go
to the 8 850 area but what will happen
here would be very important for the
future price action if we do close above
850 roughly
it would look very
good
and it would be for me a good reason to
get into this trade then in terms of
targets i mean we have some room you
guys can see the stock is you know
doing great we have completed here to me
five waves one two three four five you
guys know that i like to use elliott
wave theory that it helps me a lot to
understand the market structure and to
you know um try to anticipate what the
next move could be and here uh what i
can say guys is that we have one two
three four five abc and if we do have
this breakout above 850 it means that we
would probably start a new cycle all
right
uh
that would probably make new highs it
would probably develop uh you know in
five waves it would take some time but
it would be bullish i mean
um buying right now when you see the
potential the potential is roughly okay
just visually it can go to 70 you know
maybe something like this above the the
recent highs so it would maybe take one
year but
if we do have this bracket here this is
a long-term signal to me and the
confirmation uh would as usual guys be
given by a new high so the new high
would be here at
10 11 so if we do have a close above 8
50 and then another one a few months
later above 11
i mean i would
very uh likely try to get on uh to get
in the straight on a pullback so i'm
positive on this trade but we don't have
the breakout yet
let me check if i have this one in my
watch list
okay
no it's not there okay
but you see thank you for telling me i
will add it right now
okay so wk
hs all right
so
776
7.75 it's a stop limit
all right so
we're gonna see what it is so whenever i
have a close what did we say
a close above
roughly 850 right
8 58 16 i want to get an alert all right
so i'm going to set up this bam
the targets would be i don't know 16
the stop-loss now this is the stop-loss
i don't know maybe a 17.5 i'll see that
later the target would be around
6 60 and as you guys can see i don't
have any alert for now because here i
have a zero but look if the price
goes to
8.3 and we're getting close to it bam
then i have my alert all right and this
is how i do guys to find my trades i
just keep this watch list you guys can
do it yourself and then i check all my
alerts and today i have alerts on all of
this stocks okay and i checked all of
them and you know they're not all good
for me to go but they are all very uh
potential good clients for a strong move
up
anyway thank you for giving me wkhs it
was not in my watch list it is right now
all right guys so
um
so what else do we have
okay greg greg
jean-baptiste my friend you're asking me
three
stocks so fisel i i've done that already
rkt
xp ev
okay i missed bb so let's have a look at
uh bb first
uh all right
okay
so blackberry
very interesting one guys very
interesting one
so i did actually some analysis about
this one um
today
and what i see here guys um
as usual i like trend lines so i like to
connect the highs that i have here and
here
and i'm looking for a breakout above
this trend line which would be here
around 13
so as long as we are below 13 on
blackberry i would still be um
kind of neutral
i would wait to see how
bears react around this level but right
now we are bullish on the short term
because we have a breakout above the
strand line
you guys can see here bam breakout did
we have the volume let's check
let's check if this is a valid breakout
and you can see that here we have you
know an increase in the volume very
obvious on the on the breakout so
whenever you have this kind of um
pattern
the retest is usually good to buy so i
didn't see this one at this time so i'm
not in the straight personally
but
it could have been a very nice entry
level and right now my uh take is that
we keep going higher so the next
resistance is 12.
um
i don't think it's gonna hold because we
already tested it once you know if it
was the first time we were testing it uh
since breakouts
i would be maybe a bit um
you know
here
a bit bearish like you know bears might
try to take back control but here we
have already tested it once one week ago
so if we get back to it
it might very well break right away and
we're gonna have probably the same kind
of behavior here so same thing rejected
find more support and then let's see
what happens here but this is what i
will personally pay attention to
um as you guys can see i'm trying to you
know analyze many stocks so i cannot of
course they trade all of this stocks so
i'm just having some medium term long
term alerts
and here
here
i'm just waiting for breakout above 12
or 13 to be more bullish
all right what else do we have
okay
all right tesla
let's do tesla guys tesla is very
interesting
we have a lot of things happening on
tesla
in the past week
so let's analyze the technicals i did a
video guys about it
a few days ago
and
my drawing is still
here so i'm not gonna analyze the full
situation if you really want to see my
long term view everything i think about
tesla just go and check this video but
here i'm gonna just pay attention to the
short term so for the short term uh we
are in the fifth wave um
sorry we are in even in the third wave
of this fifth wave we already completed
the first wave uh with a breakout above
this trend line all right here there was
a very nice buying opportunity i was
there i gave you guys this trend i hope
some of you managed to get in
um
and right now we are on a typical third
wave very impulsive very explosive you
guys can see that this is just you know
the pullbacks are very shallow
very hard to get in
i think we will try to get in um
but now is of course not the right time
um
my target for this third wave is around
1 300 all right 1200 1300
uh i'm not really sure
but what i think is that we're missing
uh
one more pullback and one more funnel
move up before uh deeper and longer
correction
so
this is what i would personally try to
do i would personally try to get in on
the 38.2 retracement level
here all right so you just measure this
third wave
and
we can see that the 38.2
retracement level is 1020
so and we have
and it's not really a surprise but we
have here as you guys can see a small
consolidation if i go on the shorter
term
we have here a consolidation around the
38.2
retracement so this is another reason
for me to believe that this level is a
strong support and that
if the price action comes back here it
would probably be both heavily by buyers
like me that are waiting to get in now
can we go higher right away of course we
can of course we can we might uh
like i said we might go to 1
300 even maybe more let's see i mean you
know this has a very high potential and
what i would do if i was in the stream
which i'm not i would use uh the
you know a moving average as a training
star plus so the 20 period on the four
hours
which is right now at
1130 is a good one for me uh to use for
example so below that i would just get
out
to getting lower again
um
so yeah we're looking good i think we
still gonna go higher uh
soon but at some point we're gonna
correct and then go higher again
so this is my take on tesla
hey sandra what's up
yes i'm live
first time
okay so what else do we have
uh okay so i'm gonna go i'm gonna do uh
so archety fisa did xpev so
let's do xpev uh
some of you guys were asking me this one
so what do we have here guys what do we
have on xpev
okay let's first check
what are they doing you know it's
important because i'm very focused on ca
as you guys know but you know
it's important to know
what kind of
sector
are all the stocks so xpv let me check
okay evie again okay
great
all right so um
[Music]
so to me we had
i'm surprised this one is not in my
watch list as well
no okay i might add it later
but whatever so here we had the breakout
above um
40
that was quite clean
and it's a shame i didn't see it at the
time
uh and then we moved higher and we went
as usual guys uh to find some resistance
at the uh recent high so here the recent
high was 47
so we went to 47 and as you guys can see
this is looking quite good you know
because we go to 47 we get rejected fine
this is um kind of expected but then we
don't get rejected very low and we come
back to it you know a few times and we
are consolidating just below
so the question we're having is
uh would it is it possible that this is
a second wave because after this is the
first way for
sure and could it be a second wave not
really okay you see the correction is
not deep enough
here so i'm talking about xpev
and i'm wondering if it's the right time
to buy it and my answer is no
because i don't like to buy that high uh
the highest i would personally buy is
38.2
here so 43.
so 43 is a good level to get in i think
and i would probably add this one to so
you can see the reason we have another
recent high here in a sub wave that was
developing just before that was at 42.6
so what i like to do is to associate you
know to combine different methods and to
find levels that match
the different methods i use and here i
have one method that is giving me 42.6
another method that is giving me 43.4
the 50 is an important level as well so
41 so all this area 41 42 43 is a good
area for me to get in
uh and i might do it actually
okay
so
so let's see i think we're gonna i think
we're gonna have the second wave pull
back i wouldn't buy it now uh and if we
do have the second wave pullback we
would probably push higher uh and this
would be the right time actually guys i
had a question that was very interesting
in um on my in my discord uh it's a
question that i was asking myself to and
maybe you guys asking uh this question
to you to yourself as well
uh and the question is should we get get
for stocks or should we get for options
and you know even when i have a breakout
i sometimes think oh i want to buy calls
uh
and you know then i came up to um
to
you know a thought of process that is
basically saying that you need to buy
calls uh at the last
possible moment because the theta is
playing against you so basically
the more you wait uh to buy your calls
at the same level the better it is so
actually now i'm not buying calls in
first waves i wait for second waves you
know because you usually see those
levels again all right if you buy your
calls here but
one month after we come back to the same
level you guys know that your calls
would lose a lot of uh value so actually
buying calls dur
during a breakout the volatility the
volatility is increasing market makers
they're just you know uh pulling back
the offers so the bid office spreads are
very wide
so i don't like to buy calls on the
first wave but here on the second wave
pullback if this happens on xpev
the volatility will probably drop as it
usually does whenever we have some
pullbacks i think that going for calls
is a very good timing because if this is
correct we would have a massive third
wave so i would add this one to my watch
list i'm not going to do it right now
because
i guess you guys
are more interested into seeing
me doing analysis then just adding
things to my spreadsheets so
bam bam bam
okay
so
what else do we have yes dramatist i
didn't forget you can you look at uh so
xpv i did it fisel
rkt i can do quickly rkt but okay guys
i'm not hearing about this one for quite
some time there's not been a lot of
chatter around the stock
i mean very recently
you can see my ta is very old
okay bam
so
i was following the stock long time ago
guys and
it's not you know it just didn't do well
uh you can see we had here a breakout
massive breakout by the way massive
massive breakout
it was just being listed but this
company is heavily shorted guys all
right you know
let's have a look at the short interest
on rkt
so here guys sam i'm using bloomberg
formula you guys know that
and i'm checking
what
information i can get on the option
market okay
so
it's not massive we have total ten
percent of short it's coming from the
option market only two percent and the
regular short interest uh nine percent
so we don't have a lot of gamma so you
can see people don't really i mean um
there is not a lot of um
buyers
i mean on the option market uh that
could generate some gamma we have some
gamma around 15 so let's see whenever we
have uh
some gamma on a strike and if the strike
is actually a breakout level
15 15
really
that's weird you know 15 it's below the
current spot
all right
okay it's prep i'm surprised we have
so much option on the 15 strike
but um
okay the stock is not looking so great
we had this breakout that then got
re-tested and then we just moved below
the breakout trend line so let's do
another one let's try to have something
better okay
okay i see what you mean
i see what you mean
okay okay fair enough
fair enough it's not looking
too bad actually
um
it's almost looking pretty good
because
okay i have this trend line
here i have a nice consolidation that i
like to have below the
breakout
below the trend lines um
and then here we have a clean breakout
do we have the volume very important to
check we do so we have breakout volume
nice consolidation below and a new high
so bro thanks i like the stock actually
i like the stock
and
[Music]
it would even be
right now a good timing i mean to get in
so i won't be doing that right away
because i like to show you guys before
uh what i do before doing it
so i will
i will have a look at this one and see
if we do something but today might be a
good day even slightly below if it just
comes back to 16 17
it's still looking good to me
um
it's looking good to me
um let's try to do some idiot wave
theory here so this could be a one this
could be a two so if this is the case we
should have
three four and five so we should be in
the third so if this is really a third
actually there won't be any pullback
here all right
uh so
so if i needed to buy it i would buy it
right away
i would buy it right away uh then the
thing we need to be careful guys in this
kind of stocks
let's be honest either we have some very
good news okay that's possible some very
you know positive news about the company
and then bears usually retreat but uh
here guys we're gonna have many bag
holders
uh you know people who bought
for the past year
and that lost money uh and that just
wanna you know try to get out on um
on the rip
so
here i would personally
you know if i was in i would start take
profit early guys at 19
and i would probably finish taking my
profits at
22 so this is only a ta perspective okay
i didn't check the the company i'm not
sure
what is the business model i'm not
exactly sure
if they generate profits we can check
that quickly
okay
so
up description
rocket companies michigan base holding
company consisting of tech driven re
real estate okay mortgage and financial
services businesses all right
all right so they make money i mean
you know
they're actually undervalued
they generate profits you know those
guys they make money
they're not here for long
2 or 20
earnings per share but it's positive
i'm surprised that's why there is no
there there isn't that much short
it's actually maybe a good opportunity
to get into this one i don't know
um
sorry where's my bloomberg
okay
[Music]
and they have a price earning ratio that
is around eight so it's very low
uh
so once again i would need to do more dd
you know to dig a bit
but what i'm seeing right now is quite
positive they make money and the
technicals are showing some some sign of
reversal
uh so the question is why is it trading
so low i mean
maybe there was a bit of formula at the
beginning
but it seems undervalued to me actually
uh i would need to dig a bit more all
right i'm a ta guy um
but just from technical analysis
perspective there is a lot of back
holders i would still be careful but
maybe we're gonna have some very nice
results coming and some nice move up so
let's see but it's a very interesting uh
stock i would definitely keep an eye on
it
and see if there is something i could do
so dramatist i did all of your stocks
sandra i didn't know you did live but i
didn't know neither you know but there
is a first time for everything right
so
what else do we have
okay
[Music]
okay i can do so pltr many of you are
asking pltr pltr pltr pltr
okay
let me have a look at pltr
okay five minutes before market open
when the market is going to happen guys
i'm gonna be a bit focused
uh i'm still gonna stay live but i'm
gonna check a bit uh what is happening
on some of the stocks i am involved in
but we have five minutes left
so it's fine
pltr
all right
too many lines here let me just clean
that a bit this it's been a long time i
didn't check
let's see here
okay
okay first i don't like what i see you
know i see here fake out
and we had volume right
we had volume on that day we didn't we
did make a new high and still we got
sold why because of those bike holders i
was telling you guys all right so they
are in this trade and they are here even
when they had the breakout they still
dumped it okay so
i would personally not get in right now
i know the stock is uh very popular
uh i know that many of you are in there
but i can tell you that many of you are
trying to take profits early which is
totally fine
but for this reason
the stock
is not looking so bullish to me right
now
[Music]
okay
i'm trying to find some levels above
which i would feel comfortable
oh okay i have it
okay it's it's here all right here we go
so you know sometimes you just need to
take a step back to see the big picture
and here this is the big picture all
right it's a massive cup and handle
bam
bam okay
so this is what we're having on pltr
guys so
usually in this kind of situation look
at sense okay
okay
so
it's a bit similar to me
huge cap
handle
and smaller handle
so here we had huge cap
handle
um
so i'm suspecting a smaller handle
and then maybe a breakout so two
scenarios from here either we just break
out right now
fine okay
maybe we would
but if we do
we gonna have a breakout without a
consolidation close to the breakout area
all right
i don't have here an example that shows
this well but what we want to see is
uh the price you know doing something
like this
and then breaking out why this is the
build up area this is very important
this is where i personally sometimes
like to buy
this is an area where
you know there is
you know a shift in the
sentiment so some bears uh cut the
position some bulls come in
so we need to have this consolidations
area to give energy to the breakout so
if we have to break out right now why
not but there will probably be a re-test
so i would not rush i would wait i would
wait for this retest why because we
didn't have this consolidation area now
if we have this consideration area and
then a breakout then it's a very good uh
time to buy
so right now
i am neutral on pltr
i'm waiting to see what happens and if i
surprise trading above 27
then of course guys the next
level i would be paying attention to is
29 20 why because it's the recent high
so we could have something like this
you see this is a bullish scenario i'm
not saying this is what's going to
happen but what i'm saying is that i
prefer to buy here
than buying here because i
just basically end on the same level but
with a better configuration a better uh
setup
so this is my view on pltr and in terms
of supports guys
it's not very clear
let me try to find some support
okay the market is going to happen
okay you can use this trend trendline if
you want
okay i don't have any more connection i
have one two three
three reactions
so okay
the market is opening so let me have a
look first at jimmy guys
okay i'm going to check on the shorter
time frame
[Music]
okay
okay
i don't have many information i was
trying to find some clean uh supports
in the moving averages to get some
information about what could happen
uh and i have here the 50 you know on
the five minutes time frame i'm checking
the 50 period moving average
uh the the reason why i'm doing this is
that i have some position as most of you
guys but i will personally
and uh sorry to tell you that but lock
in some profits around 230 which doesn't
mean uh
that i would uh stop uh my long position
i would just
lock some profits and wait to see what
happens there all right and right now
unlike what i see
it's positive we come back to the highs
okay that's pretty good
and
we have this gap up it's holding okay so
this is looking great let me have a look
at amc
perfect okay for now it's holding so
it's the first minute so it's of course
too early to say
let me have a look at the global market
so what is the global market doing i'm
taking s p futures
okay so pretty much flashy
okay
he sell is not uh so great
what can we do on fisell now let's wait
you see we we are in this uh situation i
was telling you guys about is that we
are
trading below
the 8 90 level but we need to have a
full hour if we just have a candle you
know they're just coming here and
getting uh just right away above that
just like we do have right now guys on
fisel as you guys can see
it's fine but we need to have some
support coming quickly right now here
uh so let's see if this is holding
woohoo jimmy is doing amazing guys all
right plus seven percent that's great
okay
okay
okay guys
um
so
what else do we have
amc hit 50 today
yes bro i hope so i hope so it would be
great if we can go to 50 that would for
sure be a very good news hey guys let's
have a look at the i haven't checked
that today
let's see if you have some
some moves on the synthetic
short positions
so let me update that
okay
you guys know that we had around 17
million
up options on the 145 strike guys we are
coming close to 20 million all right
this is growing
okay i like that
bam 19 million guys this is great all
right this is very good news
uh we know where it's coming from i'm
still gonna have a look but it's mostly
gen 22 right
yes everything is coming from
all right
22 and deck 17
so this is gonna bring a lot of gamma
gamestop still doing great
okay so we have a lot of gamma on amc
okay the total short right now is at 25
and guys you can see the day to cover
the dtc is right now at three
so
it's quite high it's quite high for amc
but let's be honest when this stuff is
going to squeeze we're going to have a
dtc around i don't know maybe five
something like this
so
so i think we still have some time
before the massive massive squeeze
but
it's already looking quite good for me
to have some
some you know shorts starting to cut
their positions so what else do we have
17 percent of maximum synthetic short
let me add it guys let's check how it
was in the past all right because i'm
recording all of that and you can see so
i have that since the 17th of 27th of
august
i'm adding it
regularly so what you guys can see here
is that uh the
so the synthetic short
the regular short first
is rather stable but increasing a little
bit 16 19 now 18 so rather stable the
synthetic short is rather going a bit
lower but it's mostly due to the price
because the price when the price is
going lower the position of call options
is going over too and the maximum
synthetic short is rather stable
we saw it higher we saw it lower so it's
just you know everything is looking
great the reason why i'm checking that
guys is because today i'm gonna see that
we have uh we don't have that many
options here
i would be thinking that you know people
just forget about amc and go to some
other stocks but right now this is not
what i see at all so this is good news
okay what else do we have yes let's just
check quickly guys what we have for gme
okay
[Music]
wow
really
six
we have a dtc of six
guys look
ah sorry
i'm comparing
gme to amc
now let me just check gme so amc you can
see
let me first okay so don't don't look at
jme just look here amc dtc
uh was 1 1.5 1.6
point six three guys this is increasing
i didn't see that uh just before now
i'm seeing it so this is uh good news
and jme guys as well alright so
basically the short is the same but the
volume is smaller so whenever you know
you have less volumes the shorts are
panicking uh more quickly and they're
gonna start to just cut the positions
maybe
um even before some major breakouts so
they're going to add to the bullish
momentum
do you need 2 to 2 that's great
kmc42 guys something is up today right
amc plus ten percent
gme plus seven percent
okay bitcoin is going a bit lower
ethereum is still high what else do we
have football lower
sos still going lower
okay but it's not um
it's interesting it's it seems like you
know we have some flaws that go from uh
the crypto to the to amc and jme guys
okay fisel is not doing great
okay
so let's check if i have other questions
thanks jason and you're right guys smash
this like button
thank you so much
thanks for being here guys
so uh greg dramatist uh the question
you're having is a good question you're
asking me if
i should take into account the
pre-market or not
[Music]
and my answer is guys i'm i'm just i
can't stop watching jmegas because if we
do go above that level it would just
take everything with it all right
it's looking great so if um so the
pre-market is a good information for
example today you guys can see that the
pre-market was high
on
gme and amc
so it means that a lot of buyers
couldn't wait for this morning to get in
they
they wanted to get in yesterday so
that's of course bullish that's good
news now if i have a breakout in
pre-market
i don't i don't look at it
i mean i i'm
it's not a good information to look at
because it was not agreed upon by enough
investors a lot of investors just didn't
say hey yes i'm fine with
you trading at this level you know if
people are not around to um
to take the positions so just like it is
during pre-market or aftermarket they're
not here the big money players are not
here the volume is not there so the
price doesn't mean much it just gives
you some information about a little
part of uh people so it's good to look
at but not um i mean just as an
information of the sentiment but it's
not good to use in your ta don't uh
trade a breakout in pre-market or
aftermarket you know because
um even during the market you have a lot
of fake outs so if you
trade the breakouts in pre-market or
aftermarket
guys it's looking great
then it would of course not be um
not give you good signals
all right what else do we have
great to see you running a live stream
yeah thanks bro hey william
oh okay so the yes no no it's just my
maybe i speak a bit uh far from the mic
but uh i'm using the same mic but yeah i
had some issues with with the sound i
hope you guys hear me well
phu and easy daily reversal then moves
okay we can have a look quickly at those
okay but let me just check guys
guys this looks like a breakout look at
jimmy
okay
we still have some room two to five uh
to me the bracket levels is at 230 so
let's see maybe we're gonna have a live
breakout above that level
uh let's see guys
let's see what happens but it's looking
very very very good
we are close to 230
okay so i can check quickly
so p-h-u-n some of you guys were asking
look at jimmy guys
okay bam two to eight two to eight guys
i'm sorry i'm not very focused on
the questions but right now something is
happening yes two to nine
start
hmm okay
uh let me do p-h-u-n quickly and then
guys i'm sorry but i would need to be
focused on my training i have a lot of
things that i need to check
i don't want to check everything right
now you know when you're here it's my
first life threats i'm here for you guys
so i don't want to take care of my
position i want to check what you want
to see and uh right now so we can have
quickly look at ph you n so ph rn you
guys know that it's uh the stock uh of
the of trump company it got massively
pumped and massively dumped okay maybe
trump himself was selling here right who
knows um
i wouldn't be surprised that he sold
actually you know this guy he
he
you know he's a smartass that can
actually uh
easily trick
you know people the low he has
connections and
i'm pretty sure he sold but whatever uh
so here we got rejected
strongly then here we had a positive
reaction so right now on u n
uh i personally don't uh go there
because for me ph u n and dw ac were
going against amc and jme flows so
as you guys know i'm on the amc gm side
so i will not
personally put my money in there but i
understand you guys do
and
here
to be very honest uh we have this
340 350 that is a support level it got
tested yesterday once uh it might be
retested again we have the 20 period
moving average on the daily timeframe
coming here so we might see a positive
reaction here and maybe another move up
but guys remember that when you have the
strong moves down uh there are back
holders and here
maybe we're gonna have a move up but
it's gonna get i think sold quickly
and maybe do something like this all
right i don't see it going much higher
personally uh just because this is too
sharp it's not a real move and it didn't
hold uh you can see guys the real
squeeze
what they do guys they stay up okay but
i'm gonna need to get focused on my
things but uh the real squeeze guys they
they stay up i mean all right here it
got rejected but
it came back very quickly
and amc is different amc is a good
example this is you know a long term
kind of play because you can see we go
here and then we stay high for a long
time
close to the highs whenever you got
rejected you don't stay long time uh
close to uh the highs
it's not a good sign
so that's why i
i'm personally not bullish on phon and w
dwac
this
okay we have support at 50 guys 52 53 so
you know buying here stop loss at 40
is a fair try but i would personally not
try to do that
all right guys so maybe i can check if
you have a few more questions but i'm
gonna need to go
and
okay yeah maybe i had some issues with
my volume i hope you guys
heard me good enough
uh thank you so much guys for being here
thank you for asking questions thank you
for the likes uh if you didn't hit on
the like button guys do it before i stop
the stream thank you i see one more like
thank you guys i really appreciate
um and i'm gonna try to do this uh at
least once a week maybe every day
uh i will actually be moving guys from
hong kong uh very soon
uh i'm not sure exactly when i'm in the
process i will go back to france first
so i'm gonna be able to you know be with
you during the market um oh guys the
lights are coming yeah thanks
really nice uh but yeah i'm gonna be
closer guys to the us so it's gonna be
easier for me to follow you uh to follow
the market with you and then i'm gonna
move maybe to miami or new york uh so
it's gonna be even better so let's see
we have good days to come guys but even
in hong kong i'm gonna keep doing this
i'm gonna keep updating you i'm gonna
start to do more lives and i hope you
enjoyed that
much much of love guys and i see you
soon see you guys